during the commercial break I was
talking to an audience member and he
told me he went to the Coachella Music
Festival over the weekend and the second
week of the festival is coming up well
anyway this audience member asked if he
could give first-time Coachella
attendees some advice we had a whole
comedy thing planned but I thought
that's probably a good idea yeah so his
name is Rory Galloway what do you want
to say Rory
thanks Conan it's mostly common-sense
stuff Coachella is out in the desert so
bring sunscreen lots of sunscreen more
than you think you'll need actually
sunglasses aren't enough don't forget
sunscreen okay well thank you Rory that
is very very good advice thank you also
some of the music acts have glitter
cannons so try not to stand too close to
those glitter cannons the glitter shoots
out at a very high speed and can become
embedded in your face and sand blast off
your eyebrows okay well that's a word to
the wise thank you very much for that we
appreciate it Rory yeah there's lots of
party drugs out there please be careful
especially with something called purple
daisy purple daisy
yes purple Daisy it's a powerful
hallucinogen makes you think that your
hand is a delicious grilled-cheese
sandwich
[Applause]
okay well that's a good advice and
obviously concert goers should be
careful of people shooting bows and
arrows oh this no this happened today on
the freeway I could've got should
probably go to the hospital but I am NOT
missing Christina Applegate okay Thank
You Rory gala wait stop stop we'll take
a break we'll come back christina
applegate here stick around
[Applause]
you
you